Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
All right. What's going on guys.
Is Rob and we are picking back up again with, uh, swords of X.
And in this video, we're focusing on the return of mad Jim Jasper's.
Yes we are. But before we get into that,
we are going to pick up with a couple of little fun things that happen here.
A couple of little small things.
The first part of this focuses on explanation number 14,
but this is really just exposition.
And the reality is we don't really learn a lot that we didn't already know
before, but there are a couple of things that we do pick up here.
The first of these things really comes with the twilight's sword and the
twilight's sword. Of course, as it's being wielded by apocalypse,
his wife Genesis is a weapon that's part of the 10 of swords or exosomes event,
right?
It's one of the things that the forces of Morocco had to gather in order to
fight against the forces of Kakowa. But as I was reading this,
and as yesterday was basically kind of retelling this origin of certain kind,
at least as it existed on ACARA,
which is originally what her COA and the Rocco were before they were split into,
we of course get the same expedition that we always did, right?
The Twilight sword of the enemy tore the world asunder and what was one became
two. And I started thinking about this right now. It says after that happened,
that all the enemies of amaranth basically poured into the world by poured into
the main Marvel universe, right? So they came from this other place, right?
Just this, this kind of other, other dimension. And it led to him, you know,
it led to them invading the world and in seeking to capture it for the most
part. Now, of course, as a result of that, you saw two things happening.
You saw apocalypse leading the mutant population against the forces of Amazon.
And then you saw what was basically the, the white sword, right? So this,
you know, external,
this immortal mutant who basically has the ability to resurrect, you know,
him and his 100 soldiers every single morning to kind of fight the fight again,
that they went through the portal alongside with, uh, alongside apocalypse,
his wife and the various mutants who were there for the purpose of trying to
fight these forces back right now, of course,
we know that just by virtue of the stories that we've read,
that the promise apocalypse made to his wife,
as he would prepare the world as a place that could hold itself against the
forces of ament,
which is why he's always maintained this kind of a survival of the fittest
mentality, right?
This is something that you can find in our video that we did on the new origin
of apocalypse in our X-Men playlist,
where you can get totally caught up on the Xs swords event where the tennis
courts event. But the more I thought about this, and this is what's so cool.
The more I thought about this was specifically the twilight's water, the enemy,
and how his forces, how about the forces, you know, once it's Twilight,
what's this Twilight sort of merged,
but the enemy basically escaped that like all these forces came pouring out.
If I'm a betting, man, I think that's sorter. And here's the reason why,
if you go back and you look at journey into mystery,
number 97 from way back in the day,
what you had was a story whereby Odin ended up facing off against Cerner.
And this led to Cerner being locked inside the earth.
Now with some future point in time,
and we're not really told when Cerner managed to get out right. Sorta escaped,
and then just kind of showed up somewhere along the line.
This is back in the day when Marvel wouldn't necessarily provide these clear cut
explanations in terms of how a leads into B instead, it was just,
you get the end of a, and then you're in the beat. And then we don't,
you'll really get a lot of connecting of the dots that's made Chris Claremont
style of writing.
So landmark was because of the fact that he did that for 17 years, right?
There was,
it was a huge thing to kind of keep the story narrative going and everything
tied into everything else. But if it's sort of managed to escape earth,
then this was, this would explain the earth kind of, you know,
this land proximity to why it just happen to be where sort of emerged from,
but the reason why I say him and nobody else is because as you guys know,
the main weapon of sir is a Twilight sword.
And so it makes perfect sense that Cerner basically emerged with a Twilight
sword and then went and did his thing, right? And then from there, you know,
all these enemy forces came pouring out and who in the heck knows where it was
that they came from the long and short of this is that with that bit of an
explanation being offered there,
that Genesis has kind of emerged here as a person who is in effect the leader
of, of seemingly everybody right now,
initially she dawned the golden helm of annihilation,
which we talked about before,
because it was what would allow her to control the forces of amaranth.
When again, we're not really given a lot of indication here. What,
what she really points here is this notion that the forces of amaranth are
effectively leaderless and that the individual who wields the golden helm is the
person who can control them.
And so it stands to reason that if Cerner was locked inside earth by Odin and
Cerner basically formed this private army for himself and the forces of
amaranth, and then somewhere along the line,
sort of escaped that he would just leave them all behind.
And so without any real leader,
the individual who dons the golden helm basically takes over that role.
The problem with this is that the golden home cannot be controlled.
And so just because you put it on and just because the golden helm will allow
you to control the forces of MF does not mean you can control the golden house.
And that's where she says that the will of the golden home is now her will and
the golden helm wanting to get into Precoa. And so she does as well.
And that's why she's basically a villain here because her stance is we're going
to end up fighting each other to the death.
And her whole goal is to win the contest or at least for a Rocco to win the
contest so they can invade cacoa.
So that's the whole motivation behind her character.
And that's how I think sorta ties into all this stuff, but for the, the,
the goodie stuff here, but the, the good little tidbit here,
this is when we pick up with Jim Jasper's cause I feel like that's what you guys
really want to see, right? You guys really, really, really want to see this.
So here's a cool thing that happens here right off the bat.
Let me pick up with the crooked market and you've got Jim Jasper's right.
And it's basically telling his guys like, be super quick, right?
Like Saturday and will not tolerate us missing so much as a single grain of
salt, right?
The crooked market are the ones who are supplying the various foods,
things like that for this great, big, huge feast.
And this feast held in honor of the various people who are here that are
fighting. Now, this is not uncommon. And in fact,
this is really Jonathan Hickman borrowing from days gone by in older years,
it was common that when you had a war or conflict going on between two
territories, it was designed to settle a dispute.
And the conflict was being held in the location of a,
of a non-partisan third party.
That third party would actually honor both groups and basically bring forth our
champions, all feast knowing full well,
they were probably going to kill it in the morning,
but that was just kind of the way that things were done back then, right.
There was a lot of emphasis put on decorum and really the ceremonial aspect of
what it meant to get involved in a conflict. Not understand.
There's no love loss here,
just because they're all sharing dinner here does not mean they're going to be
good friends, you know, even have things like, like you've got cipher,
who's out there kind of minding his own business.
You've got storm who looks like she's kind of flirting with a new bus.
It looks like a new bus anyway. And then of course you also have Wolverine.
Who's just kind of being standoffish because this Wolverine and that's what he
does, right. He's just a standoffish guy,
but the doors officially open the banners basically fall in the hall and then
it's everybody make your way in. And as they get in here,
it's actually an incredible sight to behold.
And that was one of the things about Saturday, right? She was nothing.
If not somebody who liked everyone to know just how good she had it,
but you end up getting this really cool situation where we're basically
introduced to Jasper's right,
where Jasper's is officially recognized and declared here. And it's like,
all of this is brought to us by Jim Jasper's of the crooked market, right?
We also get lady Roma of the Fe, you get best. Bereday the colony queen of the,
the Hoff hive or the hot hive, whatever you want to call it. The famine,
who's basically the, the region of the former kingdom of dry door.
And then Jim Jasper's kind of comments and says, well,
you may not be welcome into dry door,
but you are always welcome to my crooked market. Right? If you come there,
you can find virtually anything that you want.
But here's the funny thing about this right here. So here's,
what's so crazy about this. And it's something super easy to overlook here.
Jim Jasper's is acting incredibly casual here. He's like, yeah. I mean,
come to the crooked market if you have to,
but let's not be naive about this guy.
Jim Jaspers is a guy who was so powerful that his alternate reality counterpart
was a threat to the entire multi-verse. They had to kill his universe.
They had to wipe his universe out in order to save the multi-verse.
And he was still weaker than this version of Jim Jasper's here.
This guy is a multi-vessel force. That's all this guy is right.
This guy is just death incarnate. There are very few things,
very precious few things that could stand in the face of Jim Jasper's.
Now this guy is ridiculously overpower.
Now how his power compares to Saturday. I'm not really sure.
And I would really say just pump circumstance and just being,
being polite here is the only thing that's keeping Jim Jaspers from just being
like, you know what? I'm bored.
Let's turn everybody into cupcakes and then stomp on him. Right?
I feel like that's the only thing that's stopping him from doing that.
Or just waving his hand and turning everybody into blobs of goo.
And that's the end of them.
No one here could stop Jim Jasper's if he got bored and decided to kill
everybody, that's kind of what I'm telling you here. Right?
That's how powerful this guy is. That's how powerful Jim Jasper's is.
And that's why it's so incredibly exciting to see him back because I feel like
things are gonna pop off in this place. Now,
the other funny thing that happens here is you've got Brian Brodick right.
And Brian Braddock is here. Just kind of, you know, doing his thing and,
and just sort of chilling out and Wolverine walks up on them and he's like,
look, man, you had an opportunity to basically stop all this, right?
Like when it's Saturday and took you to her,
it took her to do her bed chambers and you guys were going to do it. You know,
you guys were going to do the thing, you know, you're going to,
you're going to knock boots. Like you could have just gone through with it.
Right. And then like, none of this would've happened in the first place.
You know? He's like, well, I'm a married man. And he's like, well,
here's the thing though, man. Like, you know,
if you really cared about all of us,
you would've taken one for the team is what I would've done. You know,
I would've taken one for the team and just called it a day.
It's kind of a funny little thing. Obviously, no respectable man would do that.
But you know, Wolverine is not really a respectable guy. Right?
And so what he really does here is he kind of looks at Brian Brodick is the
reason for this whole problem. He's like, you know,
I'm not really going to be watching anybody out there.
Who's who's most likely going to die. Instead, I'm going to be watching you.
I'm going to be keeping my eye on you.
And I'm going to know that with all the people who die from cacoa,
if any end up dying tomorrow at all, they will all have died because of you.
Now, the other part of this comes with Gordon and Eliana Rasputin.
Now Gorgon is a guy that we haven't really covered too much in Marvel comics.
In fact,
I think the only time we really offered any measure of explanation on him was
during the events of secret empire,
because he was part of the hydrate inner circle. And so we could do with a bear,
a bit of explanation here,
the idea behind Gorgon's powers and the reason why he wears the mask,
the way he does is because he essentially has the powers of Medusa.
If you were to take his mask off anywhere to look at you,
you would turn to stone.
And so he wears that mask in order to prevent that from happening,
the problem with this is it takes away his eyesight.
And so Gorgon is a guy who is by all standards of measurement blind,
even if only because he chooses to be.
But he's also probably one of the best fighters in all of Marvel colleagues.
And when I say all of Marvel comics, I mean,
all of Marvel comics like this guy could give almost anybody a run for their
money. And it doesn't really matter who it is.
The other part of this is that with him and magic sizing up, everybody here,
you've also got ISCA. Now, ISCA, as a lot of the guys that you may recall,
she's a person whose mutant power is that she can't lose. And so if,
for example, she, you know, she's part of this whole great, big,
huge tournament, Newton power, you know, because you can't lose,
is that things going the way they are.
It's obvious that the forces of Gacaca are going to win.
She turned against the forces of Morocco. It's just the nature of her powers.
Now what Marvel doesn't really explain here.
And this is the problem you have with a power. That's this ambiguous,
is it passive or is it active when it comes to powers and more were comics,
you have active and passive powers. And even in DC, it works the exact same way.
So something like Superman's frost breath, that's an act of power,
but he actually has to blow frost at somebody.
But something like Wolverines healing factor is a passive power.
He doesn't have to do anything. It just automatically happens.
And so we don't know if that's the case with her or if it's active or as
passive. We don't really know. We don't know if like, you know, she allies with,
with Precoa, I'm sorry, Colby,
because she's foreseen that a Rocco's going to win. No,
she allies with Precoa or if she,
if she ends up turning against the Rocco and allies with Precoa because our
mutant power tells her Cracow was going the winter. We don't really know Marvel.
Hasn't really taken the time to explain it.
It may be one of these things where Hickman kind of gives us a bit of a tease
and we don't find out how our powers work for 100 issues. Right.
That's entirely possible.
But the cool thing about this is that because they're aware of [inaudible]
ability, the question is which side does she favor that she favor her left side,
her right side, deep do her powers go, right?
That's the question of Borgen and magic.
And so what they ended up doing is basically kind of, you know,
offering a bit of small talk, obviously giving her a little bit of a hard time.
And then as a test, they dropped at the same time.
And because she's ambidextrous,
she catches them both and it doesn't drop one drop of it. That's so I was like,
okay, like, of course she's ambidextrous. If she can't lose,
she has all the skills she needs to succeed.
And so she doesn't really favor her left or right side and fighting.
And so she doesn't really have a definitive weakness in terms of her fighting
style and turn,
she pulls the same stunt on magic in and Gordon and the magic opens a portal
that caused them to fall back through. And then of course it's like, you know,
we caught them. So again, it's one of these cool things where these foes,
these various fighters are learning a lot about each other because understand
this is the first time all of them are meeting each other, which is kind of,
it was a really, really cool moment here.
It's the first time that they're all meeting each other.
And so when you have this bit of a discussion here,
you actually end up having a having storm who approaches the horseman death.
And the two of them all start talking yellow of them kind of have this great,
big, huge conversation. Now there is a bit of a tease.
And so far as maybe storm is kind of romantically attracted to them.
Maybe it's this kind of devil may care or a bit of a mystery or intrigue,
but one thing to understand about storm.
She's not some wide-eyed girl who just stepped out into the world.
She's not naive, right? She's not a naive person.
And so while she is kind of entertaining this possibility that there could be a
romance between her and the horseman death, she basically ends at fast. Right?
And she's like, I've, I've danced with your kind before.
And I was curious what kind of person you were,
because I'm going to be fighting you.
And now that I know what kind of person you are, I know that one,
you're an honorable and respectable person, but two,
I know that I wouldn't really have any qualms with killing you.
And so from there,
you kind of picks up with Saturday and speaking directly with, with Wolverine,
right. And Wolverine is really just kind of, right?
He's just walking around like a big grumpy, lucky he usually does,
but a little grumpier than normal and Saturday, and kind of asked him like,
you know, I know when a mind is burdened, what's all what's on your mind, right?
What are you thinking? And at the end of the day, like he,
he kind of holds off and having a conversation,
but she kind of pushes him products and he says fine, right?
It doesn't have to be like this.
All you have to do is take whatever it is that you want.
And then we can end this here. There's no need for some great big ceremony.
None of this is a necessity. You're playing a game.
You're being awfully cavalier with all of our lives, for your own entertainment.
Now for Saturday, Ann's part she's in her rights to do this, right?
The conflict between curricula and the conflict between a Rocco,
happy to come up on her doorstep. And that's the nature of the beast.
When two people are fighting and their fight takes them into somebody's house,
they don't get to dictate how the person who owns that house allows them to
fight. They fall under the rules of the person inside that house. Right?
A man doesn't walk into another man's home and start telling him what's what,
that's just the way it is. Right? And so,
because their conflict led to them to this point,
she's the one that gets to call and gets to call the rules. Right?
And so that's just kind of the way that goes.
And the response you really gives here is I said,
exactly what I meant by death is the great change. Everything dies, right?
One of you guys are going to die here and everything's going to change after if
anything, I'm just curious what it is that's going to happen.
And the responsible will reign is those are some famous,
last words pops his claws and stab Saturday. Would that being said, guys,
we're gonna bring this video to an end. If you are new here to commerce,
explain,
make sure you guys are the sub button to become part of the Royal court.
If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and I will catch you all later.
Uh, uh,
[inaudible].